observe a minute silence in honor of the
22 who were killed in the attack
so that marks one minute would everyone
now please sit
in this the final open volume of my
report I deal with three topics
the radicalization of salmon abedi
the planning and preparation for the
attack by Salman abedi and Hashima bedi
and whether the attack could have been
prevented by the security service and
counter-terrorism policing
While most public interests will focus
on whether the attack could or should
have been prevented and the role of the
security service
the significance of the other two topics
should not be underestimated
it is important that we understand as
much as we can about the radicalization
of Salman abedi
so that similar signs can be recognized
and appropriate action taken
it is also important that we know in
detail about the preparation for the
attack
so that measures can be brought
which would which would have prevented
The Killers acquiring the knowledge and
materials they needed to carry out the
attack
radicalization
the inquiry heard evidence from Dr
Wilkinson
his evidence detailed the differences
between followers of mainstream Islam
who are the overwhelming majority and
are accepting of an exist peacefully
alongside people of different faiths and
those he identified as violent islamist
extremists
who believe in a narrow in-group who
believe they are the only ones with the
correct world view
they are prepared to use violence
against members of ouch groups
which includes anyone who is not part of
the in-group including mainstream
Muslims
it is important that I emphasize as did
Dr Wilkinson
that the violent islamist extremists are
a tiny group
who've adopted a distorted view of Islam
based on an incorrect interpretation of
the Quran
Dr Wilkinson outlined what he believed
were the various influences that had
contributed to Salman abadi's
radicalization
he concluded that by 2017
every conceivable radicalizing malign
presence and noxious absence existed in
Salman abadi's life
he said
I have never seen such a complete
picture of the petri dish absolutely
brimming with germs
I consider the Dr Wilkinson's evidence
was important
his perspective of the significance of
behaviors exhibited by Salman abedi was
on occasions different from that of the
security service and counter-terrorism
policing
I would hope that his evidence will be
considered with Care by the relevant
authorities to see what knowledge can be
regained to assist in the correct
identification of individuals who are at
risk of being radicalized
I have concluded that there were a
number of contributing factors to salmon
abedith radicalization
his family background and his parents
extremist views along with their
participation in the struggle in Libya
played a significant part
that struggle involved people who were
Radical violent extremists
during the time Salman abedi and Hashima
badi spent in Libya
during which they were probably involved
in fighting
they are likely to have come into
contact with a number of violent
extremists
it is likely that those extremists
including members of the Islamic State
who would be in a position to provide
the brothers with expertise in making of
bombs and in carrying out
counter-surveillance measures
as leading Council for the inquiry said
during one of the hearings
how was someone of salmon abated limited
intelligence and abilities able to
succeed in committing this atrocity
despite any safeguards which were in
place
the likely answer is
he was provided with help
I have not been able to obtain a
complete picture of the part Salman
abedi and Hashima bedi's family played
in their radicalization
nor of what happened while they're in
Libya
that is because other members of their
family
namely their parents and brother were
not willing to give evidence to the
inquiry
Salman and hashem's parents were invited
to provide statements but declined to do
so
as they are currently out of the
jurisdiction there were no further steps
that I could take
Ishmael abedi who was in the country at
the time I requested a statement managed
to leave the United Kingdom so that he
didn't have to provide information which
he was in a position to give
I have included in the recommendations
section of volume 3. some suggestions
which I hope will make this more
difficult for important Witnesses in the
future
whether if I had succeeded in getting
Ishmael abedi into the witness box he
would have assisted the inquiry is very
doubtful
what I was not prepared to do in the
circumstances of this case
was to invite the Attorney General to
Grant him immunity from prosecution in
relation to any evidence he gave to me
in order to encourage him to speak
if he was involved in the plot it would
be quite wrong for him to have any
protection from prosecution and
Punishment
there were other extremists most of whom
came from the same area of Manchester as
Salman abedi and probably played a part
in family's radicalization and or
confirming him in his views once he had
committed to Violent extremism
one of those is Abdul rayuth Abdullah
a series of messages over a thousand in
number between Abdul rayuth Abdullah and
Salman abedi sent during November 2014.
were recovered as part of operation
oliban which was the counter-terrorism
policing investigation which resulted in
the prosecution and conviction of Abdul
rahuf Abdullah for terrorist offenses
those messages talk of martyrdom
they were highly significant in the view
of Dr Wilkinson as demonstrating the
influence that Abdullah Abdullah had
over Salman abedi and the development of
his violent extremist mindset
Simon abedi was not identified as one of
the participants in this exchange of
messages until after the attack
and I have concluded on the balance of
probabilities the messages were not
passed to the security service by
counter-terrorism policing as they
should have been
my investigation however have
demonstrated that even if Salman abedi
had been identified and the messages had
been sent to the security service it
would not have affected their view of
Salman abadi
I have not criticized that view taken by
the security service but there is a
learning point which could usefully be
pursued
which is that the attitude of the
security service to those sort of
messages might be informed by the
considerations which Dr Wilkinson
applied
we know that Salman abedi visited
Abdullah in prison
and also that they communicated by phone
including by use of an illegal mobile
phone which Abdul roev Abdullah had in
prison
it was Apparent from the evidence
that while prisons were alert to the
problem of known radicalizes influencing
other prisoners they paid little if any
attention to the risk that such
prisoners who may have had a hero status
to some
would take the opportunity to radicalize
visitors or encourage those who were
already radicalized in their beliefs
there is no evidence that abdul-rauf
Abdullah played any part in plotting the
attack
but it is likely in my view that he
provided support for Salman abady's
ideological beliefs and increased salmon
obeyed his resolve to carry out the
attack
it is important that the prison
Authority do take notice of the risks
that those in prison for terrorist
offenses such as encouraging others to
go and fight abroad May seek to
radicalize their visitors as well as
other prisoners or at least support
their radical views
the government's response to the risks
of radicalization is the prevent program
a review of that program by William
shawcross has just been published and
the government has responded to it
because of that report I did not carry
out an assessment of the effectiveness
of the prevent program during my inquiry
it would have been beyond my terms of
reference to do so
the shore cross report does deal with
issues of the abated and prevent
and note that neither of them were
referred to prevent
the intelligence and security Committee
of parliament noted the same thing with
surprise
I have looked in detail at the various
occasions when family bedi could have
been referred to revent
I have concluded that he should have
been
I heard evidence that his referral was
considered at one stage but he was not
considerable considered suitable
suitable
there can be no guarantee that Salman
abedi or Hashima bedi would have agreed
to participate in the prevent program
the elder brother Ishmael refused to
engage in any way with counter-terrorism
policing officers when they went to
speak to him in 2015.
I have concluded
that there was at least a period during
summer abady's journey to Violent
extremism when he should have been
referred to the program
it is very hard to say what then might
have happened
I have looked at whether the various
educational establishments and mosques
that Salman abedi attended should have
appreciated that he was moving towards
violent extremism and notified the
relevant authorities
I consider that it would have been very
difficult for any of the educational
establishments to be have become aware
of his developing extremism
one of the problems that I have
identified is that while over the period
of his education at different
establishments Salman abedi showed
worrying signs which could have been
related to extremist views there is no
record which goes with the student which
would allow anybody to consider all
those signs together
having a record which passes from school
with a student to college or university
May well be contentious and deciding
what material to include would also be
difficult
nevertheless I do consider that it is
something which should be looked at to
see if a solution can be found
another very contentious part of the
evidence concerned the Manchester
Islamic Center also known as the
Didsbury mosque which salmon abedi
attended on some occasions
I consider it unlikely having considered
all the evidence that salmon abedi was
radicalized at the Didsbury mosque but
some of the evidence given on behalf of
the mosque about the association of the
obedi family with the mosque was
unsatisfactory
it looks as if the Didsbury mosque was
trying to distance itself from the abedi
family in a way which I did not accept
was accurate
the reality in my view was that the
Didsbury mosque did have a significant
number of attendees who were connected
to Libya but were attached to opposite
sides in the conflict
Didsbury mosque tried and largely
succeeded in providing a broad Church
where both sides of the conflict could
worship together
although conflicts were generally
avoided this did on occasions lead to
tension between the two sides
the evidence given on behalf of the
delivery mosque could have been more
helpful in enabling me to get to the
truth
the charity commission has already
prescribed a program that the Didsbury
mosque must put in place
I hope that they will read my report and
consider whether anything more needs to
be done
for reasons that I've already given I
have not commented on the effectiveness
or prevent at the program
it should be noted however the during my
inquiry several senior police officers
spoke highly of it as a program and how
successful it can be in some cases
William shawcross did comment on the
radicalization of Salman abedi in his
report
he did not have the benefit as I did of
an intensive investigation into salmon
abated case
nor did he have the benefit of hearing
from Witnesses in closed session in
order to resolve contentious issues
insofar as William Shaw course's short
passage in his report dealing with
Salman abedi does not agree entirely
with the conclusions that I have reached
I would suggest that this is because of
the much greater opportunity that I have
had to listen to and test the evidence
planning and preparation
while this part of my report is large in
a narrative event it is nevertheless
important
it is important that what was done by
Salman abadian Hashim avedi in
preparation for the attack is understood
in detail
only by doing that is it possible to
understand where the weaknesses are in
the provisions that try to prevent
people acquiring the necessary
ingredients for a bomb and information
about how to construct it
it is important that the opportunities
for obtaining precursor chemicals are as
limited as possible without preventing
entirely innocent members of the public
conducting their lives without undue
difficulty
this part of the report is based almost
entirely on the work of the operation
manteline team to whom I'm very grateful
this investigation to into the attack
conducted by greater Manchester police
was as far as I am concerned of a very
high quality
it resulted in the conviction of Hashim
abedi for the murder of the 22 people
who died
and the attempted murder of many more
who attended that night
I am as satisfied as I can be that the
brothers made use of an instructional
video placed on the Internet by the
so-called Islamic State to create their
bomb
as much as possible needs to be done by
the authorities to ensure that
instructions for murder such as these
are not put on the internet
and if they are they remain there for
the minimum amount of time
further it is important that the
regulations requiring the reporting of
unusual sales or precursor chemicals are
continually kept under review and are as
stringent as possible
that is not easy to achieve and it needs
to be made clear that unusual purchases
need to be reported promptly
none of the purchases of precursor
chemicals obtained by the brothers were
reported to the authorities
that is the situation which should not
have arisen
had they been reported it is possible
that Salman abedi could have been
stopped
I have considered the parts played by
others in the obtaining of those
precursor chemicals and other acts which
assisted the brothers in their
preparation
all of this was carefully investigated
by the police as part of operation
manteline and the evidence was reviewed
by the crown prosecution service to
consider whether prosecutions could be
brought
some of the people are still under
police investigation
but so far no further prosecutions have
been brought
the issue in almost every case
is whether the person who in fact
provided help to the brothers in their
preparations can be proved to have known
what they were providing help for
there will inevitably be suspicion and
in some cases there will be more
suspicion than in others
it is not my job to review the charging
decisions of the police or the crown
prosecution service
but for what it is worth I agree with
the decisions that they have made
I do not consider it is appropriate for
me to accuse individuals of serious
criminal offense
where they can't be proved to the
appropriate criminal standard
though I have not gone further than
setting out the way in which various
individuals assisted the brothers
I am confident that if evidence is found
which justifies a prosecution
then the police and the crown
prosecution service will take the
appropriate action
preventability
finally in my report I deal with the
issue of whether the attack should or
could have been prevented by the
security service and counter-terrorism
policing
I have reported fully on those matters
in the closed part of volume 3 of my
report which will be seen by those who
are best placed to ensure that mistakes
which were made are not repeated
in the open part of volume 3
I have included all matters which I can
safely include without jeopardizing
National Security and making our
community less safe
I have set out how I've approached the
issue of National Security and I shall
not repeat it now
except to say
that where it has been possible without
risking National Security to make public
the evidence that I heard enclosed
I have done so
what I have been able to set out in the
open part of volume 3 is that I have
found a significant missed opportunity
to take action that might have prevented
the attack
it is not possible to reach any
conclusion on the balance of
probabilities or to any other evidential
standard as to whether the attack would
have been prevented
however
there was a realistic possibility that
actionable intelligence could have been
obtained which might have led to action
preventing the attack
the reason for this missed opportunity
included a failure by the security
service in my view to act swiftly enough
I am aware that revealing what I have
revealed in part 24 of my report
will leave many people and particularly
the bereaved families wanting to know
more
all I can say is that I have done my
best to reveal what I can
had we not had cloved hearings I would
not have been able to make the findings
that I have been able to make
closed hearings I am convinced were
entirely necessary as part of this
inquiry if it was going to achieve its
aims
consequence of that however is that I
have not been able to reveal some of the
evidence on which my findings are based
as to do so would have risked breaching
National Security
while I have been critical of some of
the ways that the security service
encountered terrorism police dealt with
the information that they had or could
have had in this case
I also recognize the very difficult job
they have to do and I acknowledge their
success in uncovering a large number of
plots against people in this country
I will make a number of closed
recommendations to try and ensure that
improvements are made in the way that
the security service and
counter-terrorist policing deal with the
intelligence that they get
while I intend to monitor the
recommendations in the open volume 3
I consider that the intelligence and
security Committee of parliament are the
most suitable body to monitor any closed
recommendations that I make
they have already investigated the
attack and made recommendations
they are in the best position to take an
overall View and ensure the steps are
taken to make improvements
they also have the important benefit
that they will be in a position to carry
on their monitoring over a long period
of time
because this is my final open report I
have set out my gratitude to all the
people who have worked so hard on this
report
the lawyers the organizations who have
responded to endless requests for
information
Those Behind the Scenes who have enabled
the inquiry to keep going even in
difficult situations and are include in
that the providers of the technology
which has made it so much easier to
conduct this inquiry and of course I
thank the many many witnesses who have
given evidence to me
all have worked very hard
I am personally especially grateful to
council and solicitors to the inquiry
without whose expertise I could not have
completed what has been a very onerous
task
generally in conducting this inquiry I
have been greatly impressed and grateful
for the genuine intention and aspiration
held by so many to make a difference
and to try and ensure that nothing like
the Manchester Arena attack ever happens
again
some of the evidence has been
inspirational showing Humanity at its
best
some of it when recounting the
activities of Salman and Hashima bedi
has shown Humanity at its worth
a significant part of the evidence heard
by this inquiry has been grueling and
distressing to listen to
for example the evidence of people who
were there did their best to help
who will be affected for the rest of
their lives by what they saw and heard
the evidence of the bereaved families of
the effect of the deaths of their loved
ones has had on their lives
and who could fail but be moved by the
tributes of the families to those who
died
those who were young were so full of
promise
those who were older were achieving that
and all of them were the cornerstones of
their families
what an appalling loss which was so
unnecessary
amongst all that grief we should try and
remember the positives as well along
with the terrible events
the courage of members of the public and
many members of the Rescue Services who
did their best to help in appalling
circumstances
the response of Manchester as it came
together after the attack to support all
those who've been affected
and the efforts of the bereaved families
and survivors to try and make something
good come out of tragedy in their varied
and different ways
I am especially grateful to the bereaved
families for their continuous support
throughout the inquiry
it is impossible to imagine how
difficult it must have been for them to
listen to some of the evidence that we
have heard
I have not been able to answer all of
the questions that they wanted answered
and I'm aware that in my open report on
volume 3
I have raised more questions in their
mind
I am sorry that that was inevitable
I did ask the questions
I did get answers
but for the reasons I have given I have
not been able to report public
the what those answers were
it has been an enormous responsibility
as well as a privilege conduct this
inquiry
I can only hope that we achieve
something by our efforts
that will only happen
if those away away from this inquiry can
share in the desires of those who have
taken part in it to make things better
inevitably some of the changes that are
needed will require money which is in
short supply
but protecting the lives of the people
of this country
must be a high priority for any
government
thank you